je pense que papa est assez sévère dans
l'ensemble ceci dit j'ai eu quand même
sûrement quelques problèmes à lui
soumettre et on est arrivés sûrement à
des compromis constructifs donc à partir
nous il ya un compromis ça ça suppose
une certaine indulgence
donc il ya un mélange des deux vous
négociez avec lui j'arrive à négocier
oui donc on va y mettre du sien
est ce que vous auriez aimé que votre
père ça c'est un autre métier si je puis
dire ou une autre vocation
je crois qu'il va être peut-être très
désappointé si il apprend ça c'est
personnel j'aime beaucoup la musique
classique
j'aurais aimé avoir un père compositeur
j'aurais bien aimé faire médecine
mais en fait bon ben j'ai eu
complètement changé d'avis et je porte
mon idée sur vos repas janvier mais qui
passe médecine est-ce que vous avez
l'impression qu'ils voudraient vous
fassiez de la politique ça c'est
difficile à dire peut-être c'est
possible vous le sentez comme je le sens
un peu oui je sais pas s'il en est
vraiment conscient mais pense
qu'inconsciemment il aimerait il
aimerait peut-être avoir une fille qui
fait de la politique quand même dans sa
lignée